la scène est unique c'est le feu le roi
sait
[Musique]
je retrouve encore des personnes qui me
rabâche oui mais essayer de nous faire
encore d'autres prises de cheb hasni ce
comment j'ai fait à genzyme l'allemagne
refuse notre truc ils n'ont pas oublié
même la nouvelle génération n'a pas
oublié bien sûr c'est une légende
[Musique]
salut à tous avec l'équipe de rustiques
sont à réaliser un documentaire sur le
rail et pendant le tournage et un truc
qui nous a particulièrement marqué c'est
à quel point les jeunes artistes et la
nouvelle génération qui écoutent du rail
sont fascinés par cheb hasni chez basse
ni pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est un chanteur de raï qui est décédé
il ya 28 ans et pourtant aujourd'hui il
les inspire encore a en fait je
comprends exactement ce qu'il veut nous
transmettre sa musique tu vois tellement
tellement de souffrance tout le monde et
le monde est mon choix que moi je trouve
ça assez fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils aiment
ce
il m'a beaucoup inspiré beaucoup
beaucoup installée jusqu'au jour
jusqu'au jour aujourd'hui j'écoute
encore pour moi je suis une légende la
carrière de cheb hasni elle décolle à la
fin des années 80 et à ce moment là
l'algérie c'est un pays ultra
conservateur en fait pour bien
comprendre les chanteurs de raï ils sont
considérés comme les porte parole de la
jeunesse algérienne et notamment grâce à
leurs textes engagés à 20 ans cheb hasni
c'est l'un des symboles de cette
jeunesse rebelle
[Musique]
le rail n'était pas acceptée par les
gens avant c'était un terme au suspense
déjà le chanteur de raï ses chansons de
cabaret tu sais les voyous ah ben c'est
comme ça
[Musique]
cette musique qui parle de sexe d'alcool
de femmes donc c'était un peu
de mes voyeur avant de parler musique on
parlait faits de société
à ses dires a trouvé sa ligne de
conduite le rail à l'offre parce que
c'est une jeunesse frustrée c'est une
jeunesse qui en manque de proximité
c'est jesse vivait dans l'ignorance elle
était marginalisé elle était écartée le
rail lui va conquérir la jeunesse il
conquiert la jeunesse il va c'est lui
qui va permettre d'aller
d'aller plus loin parce que c'est comme
mon com en anglais on dit fuck le rail
du fac avec l'équipe on est parti en
algérie à oran et on a rencontré l'une
des personnes qui connaît le mieux chez
basse ni c'est son producteur et il
s'appelle nord d'une gaffe haïti
ça va
c'est bon
on est à oran on est à gambetta quand on
vient en rond gambetta ça sent le fort
dans les oreilles
c'est le fief de la ceni tous ses
copains tous ses amis toute sa famille
vivait et vivent encore en ces lieux ces
lieux historiques
c'est notre légende de gambetta
hommage à la mémoire de mon deux équipes
à la map où en est le seul ennemi féroce
des grands joueurs de la boule l'air
à ce qu'il m'avait dit qu'à cadrer
chiraquie mam on voit là l'amour talbot
l'aide
alimentaire
mondiale
migratoires
mesa multi mélenchon tu as mis en gras
ça paie plus que prends ton courage et
ta soeur at the dawn askham x mark i 4
on a tous eu on a perdu un dentiste
cheb hasni il a été assassiné le 29
septembre 1994 et son maître il a été
revendiqué par le groupe islamique armé
le gia l'une des principales
organisations terroristes en algérie
dans les années 90
c'est ici que hasseni a été assassiné et
c'est ici qu'on lui a tiré dessus alors
à amettes 2 m c'est là qu'il était
allongé on le dit souvent que des merlas
sont à la ramasse et et son coin préféré
j'étais petit mais je me rappelle très
bien de lui le jeudi on a foutu
spécialement maintenant journée à mes
filles
scheer est voix c'est ce qu'il est mais
il devrait toujours là bas sera ya
toujours mena toujours comme on voyait
ce n'est comme si je voyais mon père ou
une mère toujours content de l'avoir eue
nous donner des bonbons les grands lui
donner des cigarettes les vallons
exactement surtout il aimait beaucoup le
foot kanye brembo labs c'était son coin
préféré regarder cette plaque
commémorative il y bien c'est ici qu'a
été ravi à la vie notre ami a signé le
jeudi 29 septembre 1994 je me dis que
non 9 septembre 95 ans c'est
au moment où
ils ont lu en tirer dessus le gars il a
voulu embrasser ainsi il a détesté mais
pour les fans qui venait
abdoulaye wade leblanc
insulté en disant tu nous as
commencé depuis longtemps pour t'avoir
il lui a tiré un premier coup il est
tombé c'est de la lâcheté c'est dire
lâche qui ont ce qu'ils ont acheté
[Musique]
je me rappelle le vendredi 30 septembre
à 8h15 je suis allé à la mort c'est pour
prier pour lui et en même temps pour
demander des excuses parce qu'on a vécu
ensemble et quand j'ai vu assis allongé
il avait un débardeur noir déchiré à ce
niveau-là et
un coup de balle pratiquement noir
barraute ici et les autres à ce niveau
là
[Musique]
il y avait des gens de partout toute
l'algérie n'avait pas que des gens
dorment hervé toute l'algérie les 48
wilayas l'époque tout le monde pleurait
c'était pas facile jusqu'à maintenant on
n'a pas oublié cheb hasni il a été tué à
26 ans et aujourd'hui c'est une
véritable légende de la musique
algérienne
wonder diana
[Musique]
rim a réservé ses gonds
senna à nos fans
[Musique]
oui
bon
[Musique]
là
aujourd'hui on est en 2022 on chante
encore assaini et on achète beaucoup
plus les produits basiques des artistes
qui sont encore vivants
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu si
vous voulez découvrir notre documentaire
rails il est disponible sur la plate
forme brute 6 on vous met le lien dans
la description et si vous voulez voir
plus de contenu abonnez-vous à la chaîne
youtube de brut
[Musique]